in equalities you meet them as an
algebraic construct okay this is a piece
of algebra and therefore you can solve
it algebraically and that's fine in fact
let's go ahead and do it okay
3x minus 1 it's greater than 5 what
would you like me to do to it I think I
should probably I want to isolate X and
the fastest way to do that is to add 1
to both sides that's no big deal okay
and then of course you divide through
all 5 there's our solution okay now this
is okay but you have to be wary because
as you know what I did all my strategies
there were the same kinds of strategies
that I use with equations with solving
equations okay equations inequalities
are very much made of the same stuff but
not completely can someone give you the
example something I can do to an
equation that I cannot do to an equality
good okay so for instance okay if I have
an example like say yeah I see we do get
anything um okay okay so in this case on
the right hand side assuming X is not 0
assuming X is not 0 okay I can multiply
both sides by X that's fine right so it
would look like this and then I can go
ahead and I can solve well actually in
this case of console they go now I can
solve it okay I can't do that if it were
inequality if everything was the same
but it was inequality if I changed it to
this
I can't just multiply through by X why
not this is getting another pump yeah
good fantastic so being X is a variable
it can take on multiple values right I
can multiply by both sides here because
I can multiply both sides by a negative
number but here a can't because it would
change the direction of the inequality
okay I gave you a superficially easy
example here to start with so that you
can see how it's all fine but you have
to be careful of those this is not an
equation okay
all right now that's the algebraic
approach okay but what I've been closely
trying to drill into your head over
these last couple of weeks is but this
is not just I mean it is algebra but
it's not just algebra what other ways
can we interpret this question yeah I
can interpret it graphically right this
is statement about an object and a
certain value that I want to know where
it's when it's a bubble below okay in
this case but right so think with me and
we want to get to the point where
instead of having to draw this line you
can visualize what this looks like even
as we get to more complicated things
what does 3x minus 1 what does that
thing look like how would you describe
it if you had to use words someone
hasn't someone hasn't said anything yet
let's see here hasn't ones am I going to
volunteer so much I'm gonna always say
someone all right yeah Jitsu is pretty
easy these awake enough okay let's get
for that 3x minus 1
what does 3x minus 1 is a graph what
does it look like how would you describe
it great ok you said it has a grain of
three helping Matt guys what does that
even mean
like yeah it's true but what does that
mean ok around is 3 for every one of
those because it's very steep I guess is
the way that I would say it right
it's steep what else can you tell me
about it thank you I have a vertical
shift happy right so here's my
beautifully accurate diagram there we go
there's three X minus one okay that's
minus one what's that gonna be my third
very good okay
all right so what am I actually after
and when this graph is greater than fine
where's fine gonna be well that's
negative one I'm gonna put five
somewhere up here okay so now I clearly
have a picture for ya look there's gonna
be two right it even looks roughly like
that okay and I'm looking for their
values above the scale is not the
greatest it's enough for my purposes all
right there we go okay now this is true
I would have gotten it wrong if the
question had been to graph it however
there'd be more reasons why it's wrong
because this actually doesn't represent
the answer to this it represents how I
got the answer can anyone tell me why
those two things are completely
different
yeah okay okay so I the there's
something I didn't do which hopefully
will show you why this is actually not
the answer of this question okay which
is that I didn't label my axes okay
now you're like who cares about layaway
axes well in this case I do because this
demonstrates the fact what's obvious is
that this is a two dimensional problem
this this is a two dimensional problem
but the question is one dimensional I've
used a two dimensional tool to solve a
one dimensional problem okay so actually
my real answer should be this that's the
real answer okay which I interpret off
the graph because it's the X values that
correspond to where this is true where
I'm above five okay